e
all right good morning and welcome to
o00 we have a quorum
and representative brassie can sit in
for Senator Lang and representative
hackin Phillips for Senator
Deck all right meeting minutes of the
previous meeting do we have a motion so
moved
second any additions Corrections or
comments those in favor I opposed all
right it's hearing none thank you very
much all right the consent
agenda does anyone have something to to
agenda all right see none is there a
motion I move to adopt as
presented okay move by representative
Schmidt second by representative Lynn
any
discussion those in favor
I
opposed all
right thank you very much that gets the
consent that gets us to item
number 3A the department of of
education so this is 202
2441 this is on the um minimum standards
36.016222
five on the agenda but it's 26 this is
the first half of the 306 rules there is
a second half that has not been filed as
a final proposal yet what you have
before you is a conditional approval
and um it could be on consent I have no
substantive comments I have one note to
Jael car about um there was a comment on
the initial proposal about an in
inadequate fiscal impact however after
further review uh we we saw that it was
a existing requirement that was already
in the rules and so it it made no change
to the fiscal impact so the impact
statement was correct other than that I
have no comments on this proposal
all right thank
you I do have two people who'd like to
speak
um Christine Downing and David Trumble
who each want five minutes I hope that
you will be able to focus your comments
specifically on the
rule of that you object to and not just
saying I don't like the whole thing
because that doesn't help us to decide
if this is a legitimate rule or not um
Mr
good morning Madame chairwoman and
committee members thank you for having
me my name is David Trumble I'm from the
town aware I have a couple of concerns
about these regulations first I'd like
to go back to
1981 when RSA 541a was Rewritten the
legislature sent a request to the
Supreme Court for an opinion of the
justices on the Constitutional aspects
the court wrote back that re
administrative agencies can only fill in
the details they can't had to subtract
from or in any way modify a law they
can't substitute their judgment for the
legislature the reason for that is
separation of powers because the only
branch of government that can make the
rules is the legislature not the
executive branch so I'd like to look at
two statutes in particular that I think
these regulations run a follow of first
is 193 EB when that came about and was
updated in 2007 it was a direct result
of the London dery decision in the in
the statement of purpose of the piece of
legislation the general court said that
we embrace our duty to live up to the
Constitutional duty to fund the public
schools and it's through this statute
that we're going to Define how we how we
do accountability how do we tell the
people of New Hampshire that we're
living up to this Duty and they laid out
a rather long set of details the most
important part is that in the first
sentence of that statute they said it
has to be inputs and outputs based in
other words we don't get accountability
by is a student making progress we do it
by inputs do we have classes and
teachers and resources just as much that
has to be part of what makes
accountability these regulations
diminish the inputs part of the
regulations and I'll get into that when
I get to the RS the other statute I'd
ask you to look at is
18924 the standard School statute which
was written in 1919 but still in effect
today was just amended in the last
decade that requires buildings classes
with Furnitures teachers in instruction
this is how we Define inputs in this
state buildings classes teachers with
materials and instruction those things
are removed from these regulations so
let's look first at the current
regulations the current regulations
Define class size they use the word
class size they specifically reference
teachers who teach and give you
mandatory shell numbers of teachers they
also reference specifically each School
shall have instructional programs and
Define instructional time is that which
is under the supervision of an educator
which used to be defined as a teacher
the proposed regulations eviscerate
these regs so first of all let's look at
class size they take out the requirement
for class size they take out the word
class instead they have teacher uh
student educator ratios there's no
requirement that there must be this
number of Educators there's no penalty
if they don't excuse me sir yes ma'am
I'm sorry I don't think think that you
are looking at the um final version of
these rules cu the class sizes are are
in the rule I they're in the conditional
approval they're in the final proposal
and in the conditional approval could
you yes I noticed that that was changed
between the interim and the final and
the conditional approval request so if
you could make sure that that you're
talking about the latest version because
I know that the the board of education
has revised that section due to public
comments at previous levels I'm
referencing I went on to the doe website
last night under what's final proposal
August 14 2024 is that's the one that
we're referencing
no is
I there is a conditional approval
request which is
dated um September
11th it's in the that's in the jail car
package on the legislative website I'm
sorry it's dat is September 12th is it
not uh the letter is September 11th the
conditional approval request is
September 12th you're correct I'd like
to ask a question yes if you could refer
could you tell us what number in the in
the rules that you're reading okay could
you tell us what number you're looking
you 36 that's the one yeah that's the
one I'm looking at in the current one
the previous one was
30615 and
30617 which was called class size and Sh
had the word shall and he had to have
Educators with class size requirements
referenced later that that provision
that you had to have the local school
board shall require that each school
provides Educators with class- siiz
requirements I believe that's still not
in the it was certainly taken out in the
August one it's on page 12 of the
conditional approval it's
30614 paragraph a uh the local school
board shall establish student educator
educator ratios to promote student
learning for each learning opportunity
and learning level based upon school
safety policies content instructional
method the characteristics of Learners
and the following for kindergarten
through grade two 25 students or fewer
per educator for grades 3 through 5 30
students or fewer per educator and for
middle school and high school 30
students or fewer per educator that's
exactly the same as it was on August
14th excuse so that that has not been
changed since the August
14th uh version it was added back into
the
proposal I'm I'm I'm looking at the
August 14th one and and that's that's in
there which what you just read word for
word is what's in the August 14th one
representative fellow has a question
thank you um I'm representative fellows
I worked at the Department of Education
for 30 years and class size is not the
same as educator student ratio class
size means how many students are sitting
in a room when a class is being taught
the ratio is a completely different
number um for decades the Department of
Education has been publishing numbers
that are tell you the average class size
in a particular District or school um
education
education educator ratio if it's
published it is totally not the same um
statistic and your question
is I'm wondering why the attorneys think
it seems to be
synonymous would the department like to
answer that yeah um could you please
yourself Julie Shay administrative rules
coordinator for the Department of
Education if you continue to read that
further you'll see that it says that it
that as long as these schools shall
strive to have a class size of 20 or or
fewer so it does use class size in each
section so it talks about the student
educator ratio and then it goes further
to say that the class size is is the
that representative hackin Phillips
thank you madam chair is it also true uh
miss Shay that the definition for
educator has changed whereas the
existing rule used to just include
teachers
administrators uh in one other addition
but now under the new definition there's
several more um possible pair of
professionals who could be included
under the term
educator so in fact um the class size of
uh the ratio could affect um how many
students to actual teachers are in the
room because of the definition of
educator is expanded to include those
who do not hold a teaching certificate
or license under the state that there
could be you know for instance a teacher
and um you know special ed or um like a
pair professional who's designated to
one or two students in the classroom but
because now there are two adults in the
room that there could be more students
per this new definition of
ratio um can I address that please I I
was but going to be my next point which
was under the existing reg an educator
is a teacher or a specialist or a sta or
or
administrator 25 to one every classroom
in the state just about has got one par
of professional in it but you have to
have one teacher for those 25 students
under these regulations if it's educator
you could have 50 students in that
classroom one teacher and one perah who
could be assigned as a one-on-one to one
student which means you basically have
49 to1 that would be acceptable under
this set of
regulations thank you for your answer um
Senator Whitley yeah I I had another
question for the Department of Ed Too on
that issue um if I may so um she
reference the issue the language about
strive to ha to have but I think that's
clear um wouldn't you agree that strive
to have is very different than having a
correct I'm gonna go reference I think
that this
so looking at this
rule y so for the record Frank G
Commissioner of education and I may call
on Julie to help me understand some of
the changes that we've made so this was
the language that we worked very closely
with uh a number of the various advocacy
groups to try and um develop uh some
something that would meet everybody's
expectations um the original rule said
uh it know was focused on kindergarden
grades um two through 25 students or
fewer per educator provided that the
school shall strive to achieve a class
size of 20 students so that language is
the exact same language that existed
already in the rule and we did not
change that at
all so that excuse me commissioner so
you're you're confirming that that is
the current
class siiz rule that is effective right
now today that's correct I can I mean
and it says right in there it says I'm
reading from the current rule that's in
effect not the proposed rule um you know
grades two um uh 25 students or fewer
per educator provide that each School
shall strive to achieve a class di of 20
students or fewer per character so we've
kept the same language that already
exists in the same
statute and the current rule does in
fact say educator
correct followup please yes but but it's
it's the case that what was changed was
the language from cap to ratio isn't
that correct so but it says ratio in the
uh title because what we've done is in
the introductory so the only thing
that's changed in this rule is that in
the introduction we introduce a concept
of how you would develop student
educator ratios so it initially just
talked only about the class siiz
language and so what we've added to it
is that local Schoolboard shall
establish student educator ratios that
promote student learning for each
learning opportunity and learning level
based upon and these are the inputs into
determining the ratios that you would
have of safety policies content
instructional method and characteristics
of Learners and then we kept the exact
same language relative to class size and
did not modify that at all and the
objective here that we were after is
really there's the balance on the other
side as well um because quite frankly if
you have excuse me if you have a class
of you know second graders that are
struggling readers 20 or 25 may be too
many and so what we've tried to
introduce is this concept like you
really need to look at you know
considering safety policies you know
what is the nature of the kids that
you're working with are you working with
a bunch of autistic children or
something that need more support uh the
content that's being taught the
instructional method and characteristics
of the learning so if you're in a second
grade class and you have you know 20
struggling readers that's too many and
so what we've tried to say is here's the
minimum class sizes this is what you got
to basically strive for the maximum
class sizes but before you just default
to 20 struggling readers in a class
consider safety content instructional
method and characteristics of the
Learners so we've not changed the class
size requirement at all what we've added
is is guidance to the schools in terms
of trying to understand who's in front
of you before you just default to a
certain um you know maximum class size
number which we believe is better
pedagogy yeah so just to confirm you did
remove the cap language so now there is
no cap no no that's not not the case
there is no cap that was removed we we
the the existing language says
kindergarten grade 2 25 students or
fewer per educator provided that each
School shall strive to achieve the class
size of 20 students or fewer per
educator
the current proposal says the exact same
language there was not changed at all no
words were changed at all I think she
okay thank you representative fellows so
I just want to explain don't lose my
page that what you
see under a is not what it says in the
current language the current language
under the line a says class size for
instructional purposes is in each School
shall be thank you and then under that
is one two and three which is exactly
what you were looking at thank you
represent fellows then B what you see is
is B in here did not exist in the um
does not exist in the current I'm
calling them current you know rules
they're the currently effective rules
yes so I would just want to clarify so B
does exist in the current rule the
current rule says that you know class
size requirement may be exceeded for
study halls band course other types of
large group instruction including but
not limited to lectures combined group
instruction and showing of educational
television and films and the current one
still says student education ratios may
be exceeded for study halls bands chorus
so we basically kept the same language
in there thank you representative Lam
has a question um yes thank you madam
chair and thank you commissioner um as
I'm reading this the add language that
you added appears to accommodate for
conditions like my mother dealt with in
her third grade classroom where she had
some students who came in with no
concept of a written language and many
others that were performing at
kindergarten reading level even though
they were in third grade is does this
provide for a justification for smaller
class sizes when it's necessary because
it says that it needs to deal with the
student learning opportunity and
learning level so of course that's the
point is that basically we want our
Educators when you're setting the class
side
to not start with just some number and
say like okay we can have 25 students in
a class we're going to have 25 students
in the class you may need to have fewer
students um they were previously allowed
to have fewer students now we've listed
some criteria that should be considered
when deciding whether you want to have a
a different ratio thank you but you
still can't exceed it thank you
representative hacken Phillips thank you
um Madam chair I'm just wondering for
purposes of the the gel car committee um
internal discussions um if someone could
please point to the legislation that's
been passed since the last rule adoption
that um is directing us to change the
definitions of class size educator and
move to the class ratio
model so so just to be clear okay this
is for you that was a question
too um
the the statute if I understand
correctly
educator and the definition for educator
in the statute is the same one that's in
this rule is that correct I believe
so so which statute are you referring to
because I'm not familiar with a request
to change the definition of
educator so so we've not changed any
definitions the only changes that we've
made in here is to try and make sure
that we're aligning any statutory
definition and this is input that we got
from the legislative oversight committee
as well any definition that we've used
in here if there is a statutory
definition we've adopted it into this
rule so that the previous rules had a
different definition than the statute if
understanding director
moral not answering that question but to
answer representative hackin Phillips if
a statutory if a statutory definition
exists then that has to be used in the
rules Madam chair I don't think Madam
chair I would like to move a preliminary
objection on this issue um I think
there's a whole host of reasons why
these rules are uh contrary to public
interest which is a clear basis in the
statute for an objection I think for
three years at least parents
students Educators have raised these
exact same concerns that we are
addressing today and the confusion
abounds and so you know I I feel like in
addition to contrary to the public
interest because of a whole host of
problems that it could cause for
property poor districts uh the input
that was provided to the board of
education and the Department of
Education really was not Incorporated um
you know there are other problems with
these rules in addition to the class
size I'm just speaking to my motion um
so you know there there's volumes of of
of opposition to this that was been
considered you know this is this is
going to result as the evidence was
submitted this is going to result in
potentially schools and Property Port
districts could see a dramatic increase
um in class sizes due to sort of
pressure on school boards um you know I
think we really need to consider the
public interest here particularly for
those students who you know we we know
in our schools we have increasingly
complicated academic and mental health
needs if you're going to potentially
increase class sizes that's going to you
know lead to a situation where
individual needs are not met that's one
reason why this rule does not serve the
public interest which is a clear uh
basis for um for an objection the other
which we haven't talked about the basis
is uh we are shifting from courses to
learning opportunities we can have a
further conversation excuse that's a
basis for the objection your objection
is on this specific section is that
correct I have I so I'm I my my
objection is based on the statutory um
objection that is contrary to public
interest and I was going through why so
one is the class size section the other
is the shifting from courses to learning
opportunities which I can just clarify
to to clarify the question that was
asked there is no statutory definition
of educator we just did a search we
cannot find one that means that the
department has the ability to set the
the definition of educator they did
change it from the previous rule it is a
different definition but it is not a
statutory definition if it was a
statutory definition they would have to
use that definition but it is not
defined in the statute so just to be
clear on
that yes director moral um I think a
motion at this point would be
premature the reason being committee
rules require an opportunity for public
testimony and for the agency to
testy so so if I can I just we will we
will hold off on dealing with this
motion
which hasn't had a second yet and so we
will let the agency respond to the
comment by Senator Whitley okay and I'm
G I'll also just clarify here so the
change to the definition of
educator um was in the old rule it made
reference to RSA
18939 which only included superintendent
superintendent so it the the old rule
had an incorrect citation to the statute
so we've not made a substantive change
we've made a technical correction to it
if you look at the old definition versus
the new definition um and Senator
Whitley I just think it's an incorrect
characterization that says that uh this
would allow for unlimited class size in
fact this rule was from the initial
proposal was
modified specifically based upon that
public input to provide class-size
limitations as we've just explained and
those are in this rule so I think it's
an incorrect characterization to say
that there are no class siiz limitations
because they're very clearly enumerated
in the in the rule
set thank
you okay Madam chairwoman can I comment
please I'd like to respond to two things
that the commissioner said he he said
that they didn't make any changes
there's two important changes that were
made one is this issue of educator it
may be in their point of view a
technical correction but it changes the
impact of how the regulations play out
in the real world because right now you
need one teacher for every 25 students
under the way these regulations are
currently worded you could have one
teacher and one perah for 50 students
it's it's more than a technical
correction the second thing is that if
you look back two sections before the
numbers section where you have the 1 to
25 the previous set of rules which had
been in effect until just a moment ago
says to carry out the educational
program established by these rules the
local school board shall require that
each school provides Educators in
accordance with class siiz requirements
in
30617 that has been stricken from the
one that was written in August and I
don't think it's in the brief chance I
had to look at the one from September
that precedes other words the number
section is the number section but the
section that came right before it said
You shall do what's in the number
section so the shall do part was
stripped and the numbers part was
changed the effect of those two changes
is to mean that you could have 50
children in a classroom with one teacher
and one parah under the the rules that
are being proposed that would not be
acceptable in the status
quo thank you okay I have one more point
that I didn't get to get to we kind of
got a bunch of others people speaking
can I please make my my second your last
point please okay so the first was class
siiz the second is the issue of
instructional program and again I go
back to RSA 189 that says there has to
be instruction that's a statute it was
required 193e set up how do we measure
accountability it's instruction based
it's there's a long whole section in
there the current regulations I'm I'm
using current for meaning the ones that
have been in effect for the last 10
years in section 26 which is
kindergarten through 8th grade and then
the next section which is high school
reads simply the local school board
shall require that in each school there
is an instructional program that
includes and then methods and strategy
for teaching you have to have an
instructional program in the present
system and that must include teaching
you have to have teachers who teach RSA
189 says they must be teachers who teach
these regulations remove that they took
out the word instructional progam please
point to the part in the current in the
rule under
consideration you made that change okay
so again we can follow it okay great I'm
sorry I'm using the August 14th one
let's see if uh the same n section
number right
okay if you go
to um
30622 for instance High School
curriculum thank
you credits and curricular
programs it says um the the required
locally improved curriculum content
shall comply with the following the
program of study shall include those
learning opportunities in which students
demonstrate achievement of competencies
the first point I made has been lost
here it was the Statute 193e says you
have to have inputs and outputs equals
accountability both this rule says that
all the curriculum has to have is a pro
program of studies that includes
learning opportunities in which students
demonstrate achievements of competencies
there doesn't have to be an
instructional program anymore there
doesn't have to be a class with teachers
with instructional programs and the
second half of this that you're going to
get next month which should have been
included with this for a fair
examination of it required that for each
subject that's listed in 193e at the
each of the three levels elementary
middle and high school there's like
eight things you have to do for math
eight things you have to do for social
studies and it had the word shall for
each one of them that was stripped in
the regs to make it may the statute says
you have to have instructional programs
that are taught by teachers the current
regs said instructional programs taught
by teachers the Cur the future
regulations got rid of the learning Pro
the instructional program language and
just call some learning opportunities
the only way we know if we have
accountability is if people actually
achieve the competencies but there's no
penalty what if only 20% of the children
achieve the competency there's no
penalty there the only way you know if
you have accountability is inputs and I
would lastly reference you to the conval
case the judge in that case please let's
not confuse us with the Le all I'm
saying is he he looked at that and he
said how do we know how much we have to
spend he said I'm going to use the input
space system because that's what's
required by the Constitution that's
what's required by existing statute the
regulations should match the statute it
should be inputs based thank you you're
welcome there were other questions
representative fellows um yes I'd like
to talk about use of the um word
educator so from the current statutes
which defines Educators to include
administrators Specialists and teachers
it is clearly changed in the new statute
but in both the existing statutes and
the new ones excuse me are you talking
about statutes or rules I'm I'm rules
I'm
sorry so okay yeah yeah so in in the
existing rules that we're um have and
the ones that we're looking at to be
changed the definitions are different
but in both cases throughout the entire
rule when you look at it where the word
educator is used which is in many places
it's clear that the the individual
rule does not apply to all of the um
characters that are identified in either
of the definitions so it I mean it
doesn't make any sense because I was a
business administrator for a school
district I I had no business being in a
classroom so you know you just have to
take that for the way it is and thank
you it's too we' be nice if we could fix
that but that would be a that would be a
big project to fix
that you have the department has a
comment yeah that would if you're a
business administrator you're not
qualified you would not by these rules
you would not be eligible to be an
educator in the classroom so doesn't it
say though if I you have to be certified
to be a business
administrator not well first of all we
don't have a business administ
administrator certification and we've
enumerated an educator the various R did
you get rid of it because I used to have
a cert a certif it's been gone
certificate yeah this board approved
that rule probably about 18 months ago
um that's been gone for some time now hi
Elizabeth Brown to identify myself I'm
councel for the Department I've been
involved with these rules um with Julie
Shay um throughout and I just wanted to
come and make sure that I was um cleared
up the question here about the
instructional program being removed
instructional program is a a term that
is defined by Statute it wasn't defined
program importantly in these rules um
because really that's what we were
trying to do when we were going through
the old rules there was a lot of in
congruence between uh the rules
themselves and like and statutes and
rules and so we were trying to go back
and have Fidelity to the educational
statutes in these rules and that was
really um my focus um I'm an old trust
and Estates lawyer so each word has
meaning kind of uh training and that's
the kind of fidelity that I laid these
when and we were doing these
administrative rules to the statute and
wanted to make sure that we were very
very careful in using the same word in
the same way in the rules that we were
using in that the legislature had used
in the statute because that Fidelity is
so important and it had kind of gotten
lost in the mix and we had created kind
of a different nomenclature in the rules
um and I think that led to a lot of
confusion so if you go back to 306.000 2
if you look at program program is
defined now it means a grouping of
interrelated activities opportunity and
resources designed to implement a
particular goal also because these are
intended to be you know Competency Based
uh learning we've defined you know uh
learning levels but we've also
defined
um competencies and we've gone back to
define those specifically not in some
other fashion but exactly how the
legislature has done so so I mean that's
the really important thing here is we
may have taken out instructional program
I'll give the gentleman that but if you
go back and you look at the fact that
we've adopted educational program that's
the language that's now used we've
defined program we've made sure that
that follows with the statutory
definitions it's very very much trying
to create a very close correlation to
the work of the legislature and make
sure that these rules Implement exactly
what the legislature has given the State
Board the authority to do so
um speaking to the back half because I
think there was an initial draft that
was brought before the board as an
initial proposal um that included the
word may instead of the word shall um
you would note if you went and pulled
the um um board packet that was before
the State Board um on Monday that is not
the proposal that went before the state
board that is not the proposal that the
state board approved on Monday the shall
shall be there it is very consistent
with the um statutory authority of the
state board and the manual and and the
process and the procedures that Jael car
has demanded of uh rule making bodies so
if you rather than uh pontificating or
trying to talk in theory about what was
in front of the State Board um back in
February I think that before we have
that conversation you need to go look
very specifically at the proposal that
was approved by the state board on
Monday it was very different um and we
had actually had a conversation with 's
attorneys um and tried to make sure that
we were uh following process procedure
and we were keeping Fidelity both to the
administrative rules process and
existing law so I think you know we've
got to be very careful when we're
talking about different proposals that
everybody's on the same page and we're
talking about the same proposals and
right now we're kind of passing as two
ships in the night in this
conversation thank you so can I uh
summarize your comments by saying that
the old rules were not necessarily
properly aligned with the statutes which
God knows have been amended many many
times and the part of the confusion is
that some of the language that's been
carried forward in the old
rules has been changed because it is no
longer supported by the statute is that
correct yeah there was that that's a
pretty good summary and and we really
tried to go back very
cautiously um and carefully and go back
to see if there were definitions to uh
things that were in the rules and we
found by surprise that the legislature
had done our job for us and so our job
if you're if you've defined a term is to
use the term that the legislature has
used and so we have gone back between
the time that the initial proposal went
before the state board and this proposal
came before your body we have done a
very careful process of that word for
word evaluation of this and discussion
with the state board on why we have done
that because we want to keep Fidelity to
the education
laws as they currently exist thank you
madam chair yes may I might make one
response to that yes thank you I I
understand Fidelity and I think that's a
good goal the the definition of program
says a grouping of inter related
activities opportunities and resources
nothing in there says teachers who teach
students if you look at the existing
regs it's an instructional program is me
methods and strategies for teaching
students if you go back to RSA 18924 it
requires that in these schools it is
taught by teachers that's
statuto required in existing law so I
think there's some Fidelity that get
lost I understand the idea for
alternative education and that there are
other options that could be applied
that's good but what these regs do is
say we're going to take that and make
that the the minimum requirement for
everybody which is different than what
we have in the presentent system we
should take what we have now keep it and
maybe add on some of these alternative
opportunities and activities but not
replace having teachers teach students
That's the Law we have right now statute
law I use that word specifically thank
you you're welcome representative Leon
um thank you madam chair um sir I if you
look to the rules that are in the
conditional approval packet I believe
that you will find that all under
educational program in the Ed
30612 um I recognize how challenging it
is to go through all of this and I'm
benefiting from the find function but I
see that I I see the op where somebody
needs to be licensed if you you can only
do so much outside of where you're
credentialed and I believe that that is
all in these rules as they're moving
forward um if I may if if you look at
18924 which is standard
school um it is the only definition of
school that appears anywhere in the
education statutes um it is an awkward
rule to try it is an awkward statute to
try to employ it doesn't mention
teachers anywhere um but it is the only
definition of school that the department
has to work with something the
legislature might want to consider um
but it but there's nothing there about
teachers it's simply it says a standard
School shall provide instruction in all
subjects prescribed by Statute or by the
State Board of Education for the grade
level of pupils in attendance it that
doesn't even tell us by who the
instruction is supposed to be uh
provided by so that definition of
standard school doesn't get us anywhere
thank you madam chair one on one reading
right off of 18924 right after that part
it goes taught by teachers are we not
reading the same
statute that's
not it says current through the 2024
legislative session yeah right there
taught by
teachers okay go ahead all
right um just to clarify our process
also um the
department submitted an initial proposal
and that initial proposal had comments
almost on every
page that initial proposal and the
comments and the public comments that
came in for that initial proposal went
back to the Department of Education and
they created a final proposal draft that
final
proposal was the the purpose of it was
to satisfy our comments as the committee
attorneys and as the public
um made comments on the initial proposal
so the two texts are not the same and
the that I think is very important here
because if you're looking at the first
one it is not the same as what we're
we're talking about now they filed the
final proposal it it satisfies most of
our our comments and the comments that
we had heard from the public and then
they did a conditional approval to clean
up some other things and so that's what
we're reviewing now so I just want to
make sure that everybody knows that it's
it's the conditional approval that we
are reviewing from September
12th and again I have no comments on
this proposal okay could um May I just
bring your attention to 30612 because I
think that may better address um the
issue if you go through 30 6.12 talks
about provision of staff and staff
qualifications and it goes through the
particular requirements of what a school
has to do in order to carry out the
educational program and so so it gives
it goes through and it tells what the
services have to be provided how they
have to be provided by um licensed
educator how a school district has to
hire and train their Educators that
they're licensed under the 500 rules
facilitate learning in their credential
dat content area so I think if you look
okay Madam chair Is there further input
that we need to receive
ex yes thank you Mr tremble welcome
thank you very
much representative fellow um yes I was
just thinking um
that in 30612 it uses the word
educational program in the definitions
it uses the word program which does it
says particular goals it doesn't say
anything about a curriculum or academic
standards it it's I I don't even
understand why there would be a
definition of just the word program even
in here it makes no sense thank
now you turned it
off now it's on okay sorry um Christine
Downing Goan New Hampshire um 30 plus
year educator um all the way from
elementary middle high school teacher to
principal to active curriculum director
right now um I I do want to make a point
of clarification and and I am going to
draw to two references and I hate to do
this but I am going to labor that
definition of AD of educator for a
second um but before I do that I Ran So
this committee is full fully aware as a
volunteer I was not part of um the
national coun uh Center for Competency
Based learning but I ran 10 educator
review sessions in the month month of
March of 2024 throughout this state I uh
got feedback from over 300 Educators and
I am going to go on public record today
to say that the language around the
educator um student ratios and that
class- siiz language was not recommended
by the Educators in fact they suggested
edits to the existing rules that would
clear it up so that I am going to go on
public record and I have the data if
this committee would like that data to
to look through to back up that
Educators did not support that we would
appreciate it I don't yeah um I'm not
concerned that the data on how many
Educators supported it I would like to
have the specific edits you referenced
sent to the committee yep I I can do
what the edits were that they they
suggested the Educators themselves
suggested I absolutely can do that for
you absolutely Madam chair um I want to
just go back to the educator
conversation about what the current
rules say the current rules Define
educator as means any professional
employee of any school district whose
position requires certification by the
state board pursuant to RSA
18939 the term includes administrators
Specialists and teachers that's what
exists currently in the rule there was a
comment made that RSA
18939 was irrelevant because it spoke to
superintendent but I want you to hear
what
8939 says because I'm going to contend
today the removal of that significantly
changes the definition of
educator 18939 currently effective as of
2024 says superintendant shall nominate
um shall nominate and school boards
elect all teachers employed in the
schools in their school administrative
unit providing such
teachers hold a valid educational
credential issued by the State Board of
Education the removal out of that of the
definition of educator and the addition
of particularly and believe me I value
our par Educators but the new definition
list all these people and basically just
says those who are credentialed by the
department of Ed what you need to keep
in mind is that a par one certification
only requires the completion of a high
school diploma by the definition in
these new rules we with these whether
you want to argue their educator ratios
or class sizes here's the situation it
creates and this is a real world
situation I'm dealing currently as a
curriculum director currently I am in a
small rural School District where I have
one teacher per grade level we had an
influx of enrollment in our second grade
it bumped our second grade to 28
students okay so it bumped them to 28
students if I took today's rules I would
need to go to my board and say we're
going to have to figure out another
teacher we're above it if I go to the
rules that get passed the they're going
to be able to say we don't need a
certified teacher which is going to cost
us more we're going to put a par in
there now here's what I'm tell I'm going
to tell you because under the new rules
that per would be defined as an educator
and we would now be at a ratio of one to
four teams so we be under what's
stipulated as a proposed rule that being
said the responsibilities of those 28
students when it comes to instructional
programming lesson planning assessment
meeting with P parents falls under that
teacher this is the and and to use
represent uh Senator Whitley's language
there are many contrary points in these
rules to the rsas themselves exactly
what David Trumble spoke about about the
RSA and I I totally respect the State
Board of Ed and the department of Ed for
the Fidelity conversation of holding
Fidelity to the RSA but let's do our due
diligence in these
rsas the the change in that term of
educator is what's creating
inequities in our school districts my
board with if these rules were adopted
and passed my board could say we're just
going to add an educator another another
District that's 20 miles away from me
who has decided to put a uh policy on
their local level which they could do
I'm not going to argue anybody that um a
school district can can set their own
requirements for class sizes and ratios
could decide to do a policy where they
limit and make that decision because
they have that kind of financial ability
to do that and hire other people whereas
one of my rural districts that doesn't
have that Financial ability
won't set that policy and they defer
back to these minimum standards approval
we have to think of the lens of equities
to our schools across the state for
these rules now I am going to give up
another whole section thank you for the
time but there are concerns in section
and here's where I want to bring some
concerns to light I hear the
conversation about Fidelity and Fidelity
to the RSA particularly RSA
193e 2A which is the definition of an
adequate education and here's where I'm
going to start to pull some things out
in a tech advisory that was written in
September of 2022 by the department of
education related to personal finance
literacy they used the interpretation
that in in RSA 193
e2a paragraph 1 when it lists out the
learning areas that should be included
as the definition of adequate education
they unilaterally interpreted that list
to mean they had to be Standalone
classes here's what I mean the original
law that governed the implementation of
personal finance literacy clearly stated
that personal finance literacy could be
integrated and applied into other areas
yet in the proposal in
30622 here where they list the
graduation credits out that they're
proposing they're going to hold them
steady for now but for the following
year they're proposing a half credit of
personal finance literacy where in the
RSA does it give them the authority to
usurp the law that was written that
implemented personal finance literacy to
be integrated to now be a standalone
credit which most will interpret as a
standalone course it doesn't and in fact
when that law first came out many high
schools incorporated as the law had
stated personal finance competencies in
their economic classes which were a half
credit by adding that half credit to
personal finance literacy they took a
half credit away from our New Hampshire
students in their electives they
eliminated student agency and choice and
voice in what kids can do to design
their learning Pathways in high schools
that's the very essence of Competency
Based education another example I will
give you real quick again in
30622 going back to the Fidelity of RSA
193e 2A is that in paragraph 1 section B
it clearly also says that logic and
rhetoric shall be integrated and applied
yet again they pulled out logic and
rhetoric to make it its own half credit
again taking electives from our
students we are minimizing if these
rules move forward we are minimizing the
high school experience for our students
to be a compliance checklist we are not
making our public schools a place where
kids can explore and find out who they
want to be I can continue but I'm not
going to eat your time up I've got more
examples like this I will be happy to
submit the written details of more
exemptions like this that exist in the
effort to make things have Fidelity to
the rsas it's been a pick and choose
when it comes to the Fidelity one other
quick thing I will point out is that in
that same section
I believe it might be under Section 3
within 30622 there is a list of areas
that high schools are supposed to have
in that list it contains business
education yet it removes family and
consumer science the board discussed at
its meeting how they were removing it
because family and consumer science was
not listed in RSA
1932a to Define an adequate education
okay I recognize that you're trying to
be faith F to that RSA then my question
would be then why is business EDS still
in the list Fidelity is Fidelity you
hold it as a line you don't choose when
you want to have Fidelity and when you
don't thank you thank
you thank you very
much Madam chair yes I I'm just
wondering if we could ask Miss Downey to
send us those examples in addition to
the uh comments that were made on
educator but also the examples that you
have in these kind of in these kinds of
situations in addition to besides bu
business education and that would be
very helpful thank you would absolutely
it would be helpful to me if it's okay
with you absolutely I just need to know
is the current list on the website like
current with all the active members I
want to make sure I get everybody yes so
yeah okay y I will use the website and
you like the department to uh comment
sure I'll try and clarify some things
and we so appreciate the work that uh
Miss Downing did uh in terms of
gathering um public input from many of
our Educators um and uh we meticulously
went through that input and tried to
incorporate any comments or changes that
they had um into this rule set and we
believe with Fidelity we have included
those those um I'm just includ you know
I'm happy to answer any questions but I
will also just address a couple of the
the items that she brought up and again
we still seem to be going around about
this concept of educator educator as a
term is used throughout this rural
proposal but I will again point you to
Ed
30612 uh provision of staff and staff
qualifications where we talk about to
carry out the educational programs which
are required in these rules the local
school board shall require that each
school provides um and under two it says
professional staff member licensed by
the department in accordance with 500
and uh 600 under B it says and that the
an educator with sufficient content
knowledge as determined by the
superintendent may be assigned to teach
in a Content area in which they are not
licensed only as a minor assignment um
so it is not that they can just be
randomly assigned to educate that would
be a violation of the laws if you put a
par educator who didn't have content
knowledge and responsible for running an
educational program um the second thing
20 credits required to graduate from
high school that's the minimum number of
credits that are required to graduate
from high school most schools have more
than 20 credits as the number of credits
that they acquire um in that initial
list six credits were included as
electives for the students um the
board's conversation around this so and
then in the proposal they're saying that
they should have four elective credits
not six elective credits um part of the
conversation that the board had around
that is they said if we are you know
we've got compulsory education laws so
these students are required to be in
school during the time that they're in
school we want to make sure that they're
getting the information that we want and
we want to make sure that we're not
communicating uh that an entire year of
high school which would be five credits
is uh you know kind of uh voluntary
because then if you think about it most
kids would basically be able to complete
all of their academic requirements in
three years of high school and then they
can spend their entire senior year just
taking elective credits so we've
continued to leave four elective credits
in there but they have uh you know
required some additional changes to that
including uh you know in the mathematics
area they added a half a credit in
statistics and Analysis um and then they
split out some of the other credits
relative to the bill that was passed uh
SP 216 by the uh the Senate relative to
requiring certain history uh government
and constitutional classes that they put
in there um um as well as it is as
Christine pointed out the uh the board
uh believed that the financial personal
financial literacy was uh because it's
enumerated in that list was something
that um you know that this body uh
wanted the students to have a dedicated
personal financial literacy class uh and
so that is how that was understood by
the the state board when they were you
know discussing the table of credits
that would uh take place here um I don't
disagree with Miss Downing that uh and
consumer science was not on the list so
if I go back in that particular rule uh
where we talk about the classes that are
required to be offered right so not
credit requirements for graduation but
credits that are required to be offered
um the board did remove CR family and
consumer science because it was not
enumerated um in that list the board had
a conversation and believed that that
was incorporated into uh content areas
such as social studies personal
financial literacy and economics um and
was encapsulated in there um as well the
the jail car comments that we received
uh pointed out the fact that these were
not on that list um but business
education was not one of the jail car
comments that we received so we left
that on the list uh in terms of uh
credits that schools are required to
offer I don't know if that helps
so if I understand correctly the
legislature has added specific
requirements in the last few years that
weren't in the previous rules that are
incl in included in these rules that's
correct the number of open electives has
been decreased
deliberately despite and
the um specific items that were pointed
out as needing to be addressed for
example
um personal
finance are are specifically called out
that's correct so in this rle proposal
the board believed that the
legislature's intention was that
students would have a half a credit and
okay I'm sure that that's that's the
minimum but I would hope that more of
them would do more than that um business
education doesn't appear to be on that
list that I can see but it is a
requirement that the schools offer it
correct is not a graduation requirement
but it's required that the schools offer
business education and what is included
in business business education that's
not economics so that's enumerated in
the back half um and so it includes a
variety of subjects that are
competencies developed through the CTE
programming thank you does anyone else
represent CH Senator Chandler thank you
very much I my question may be more for
um jel car the attorneys than the
department but I appreciate your input
as well um you know change is difficult
for all of us and I do think it's
important that we have these robust
discussions um because because we we
we're going to make a change it's going
to be in place for quite a while we want
to make sure we're doing it right and
commissioner you just mentioned
something that is really of concern to
me and that is the back half so we are
May the question uh raised by our chair
is a good question and we're going to
get the answer we it's potentially that
we won't get the answer until after this
approval I'm just my question is should
we be doing all of this at once would it
make more sense um and is that practical
so as I say that may be a question for
many would that other section be ready
for our our October meeting uh I don't
believe it'll be ready until the
November meeting the deadline for this
is October 18th jel car would need a
waiver to postpone it until until the
department is ready I have a question M
I'm chair yes represent when would these
let's just say when is the effective
date because the your rules have not
expired
correct no the rules have not expired
they were filed before the expiration
date which means they continue in effect
until the process is over okay so
there's no pending rush for these things
and the department will determine what
the effective date is considering
correct and so we've included some
effective dates so for example on the
minimum you know the graduation
requirements there's two dates we gave
schools two years in order to be able to
Implement that any changes associated
with that I believe so okay so that none
of them affect the current school year
is that correct other than making sure
that
the so for the change so if you look at
the the draft there are two tables that
have graduation requirements because we
wanted to give students the opportunity
who who have already gone into high
school not to have the graduation
requirements changed or altered while
they were there and so the more we delay
these then we run some risk that um
students would have the rules changed or
we would need to delay the changes even
further which might not necessarily be
consistent with the legislative intent
because they've changed some of the
requirements under 193 e2a in the recent
years and so we're just delaying the
implementation of those changes right
but it but for the purposes of the
students I don't know how many of them
are having quar or credit courses but
most
so the for someone who is a senior this
year you're not are you changing the
requirements at all no no anybody who's
in the system gets to stay with the
current system until they complete fine
then I think it's although it may be a
nuisance for planning purposes I agree
with the senator that we should look at
the entire package at once because they
appear to be
interrelated if Senator Whitley if
you'll you'll uh postpone your motion
I'll withdraw my motion all right then
then I'll move that we request a waiver
and
defer
um consideration of this rule until we
have the other
half which is estimated to be the
November meeting
okay all right any comments
discussion I think that makes sense okay
I do have one question yes and we may
not be able to answer that but part of
the um responsibility of the legislative
oversight committee and education is to
review these the curriculum rules in
particular so I just want to make sure
how that the oversight committee is
charged with um reviewing the academic
standards these are not the academic
standards that's correct I understand
that I'm talking about the second half I
just want to make sure that when we get
there everybody's on the same page and
everybody's on the same bus okay that's
that's my question and that's my
statement that makes sense any other
comments those in favor I I
testimony
agriculture okay this is um animal popul
population control 2024
51 this is an incomplete filing there is
no summary of public comments I have
requested it several times and have not
received it so there is no public
comment summary on this proposal um
there is also there are some um
substantive comments um legislative
intent for requiring a social security
number um which needs a specific statute
author statutory Authority for and the
department does not appear to have that
and then there's also some clarity is
isues um for example in uh agriculture
28020 they're using multiple
conjunctions which makes the the
paragraph you you can interpret it in
several different ways because they're
using both the the and and the or
conjunction um there's also another area
where they talk about checks and award
letters but those are not defined or
described
um and so there's some some serious
rules
okay thank
you does the department have a
comment please turn your microphone on
thank thank you there you go um sorry
about that uh Patricia Benner I'm the
legislative coordinator um primarily
hearings officer for the Department um
and working part-time so uh there's a
lot on the the agriculture plate however
um so I do apologize for uh lack of uh
completeness the um I believe we
included in our cover letter um I
believe it was um explanatory notes
rather than a public comment summary was
the title um there were no public
comments um so that's all right well
that explains why there's no
summary um just just to be clear even if
there are no comments you have to submit
a summary to tell us that there are no
comments I I in there it just wasn't
titled correctly um so uh and then I I
do agree that there are some edits to be
made
um
editorial uh but the in regards to uh
281.50
3 uh the proposed would be L uh
regarding the Social Security number so
this is really a requirement for the
vendor ID um it it's pursuant to
whatever process Das has set up so it
it's how they get paid
so I I think that the authority is
within the rule it's within the statute
to allow Das to establish the payment um
uh no it the any rule needs specific
statutory authority to collect a social
security number it it's it you can't be
derivative unless you unless you say
here is the vendor identification number
means the number assigned by da as per
their rule which may be the case and let
them collect the data
okay that makes sense so that is
something we can work with uh leg the um
office with specific language on that
Madam chair yes
representative ask a question yes thank
you so you say that there was no public
comment but did you have a public
hearing and if so what was the date of
that hearing the public hearing was on
April let me get the exact for
yeah and where was that hearing held it
Agriculture
okay there were no attendees and no
public
comment and I trust that every
veterinarian in the state was sent a
notice I don't have personal knowledge
of that Dr Crawford actually started the
process of um this Rule and he he was
the one that attended the public hearing
so I was not involved until recently um
so okay CU I would I can't address the
committee with that just glancing at the
rule it appears to affect V
veterinarians specifically and they and
noticed
okay all right any other
comments
questions in that case I would move we
have a prelim objection based on staff
comments I'll
second because
you besides the
um um editorial issues you really need
to look at the Social Security Number
issue and figure out who is authorized
to ask for that if anyone is
yes and if I could also ask the um the
department to get back to us on whether
or not veterinarians were notified of
the public hearing as opposed to just
something who was
notified who was notified who was
notified besides just putting something
in the newspaper the but besides the the
regist regist
correct that's not something that I
would imagine most people in the state
read
religiously
I so yes we like to know if anyone and
we will I'll we will ask Dr Crawford who
was specifically
notified all right is and uh any further
discussion comments
questions all right seeing none those in
favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
luck all right
Dees so this is proposal 2024 53 The
Collection storage and transfer facility
requirements the only comment I had on
this proposal was a note to the
committee letting them know that the FIS
indicated that there would be a
potential increase to the in cost to the
political subdivisions so we did take a
further look into that um the rules the
potential cost would be adding a permit
by notification for collection centers
for non select recyclable materials and
I had to get clarification from the
Department because I didn't quite
understand what that meant and and
essentially a non-select recyc material
is something that is not comprised of
paper cardboard glass plastic your
typical recyclable material so for
example it would be vegetable oil or
tires so it seems like a completely
voluntary program or service that towns
would provide their residents and based
on an analysis of the case conquered
city of conquered versus State um I did
not see that there was a
violation of article 28a of the
Constitution so I just wanted to make
the committee aware of that but besides
that I had no other comments okay and my
understanding is that a permit by
notification is much less of a problem
than a normal normal permit yes I I did
reach out to the department about that
as well and they explained that there is
no fee to apply for that permit and it
is a much easier process than their
is the department
here you any any comments or information
for the committee no
okay does someone have a motion in that
case
approve second okay moved by
representative Schmidt second by
representative Lynn those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
that's that one
additional
requirements the next one is
22456 it is additional solid waste
facility requirements um and the issue
with this rule is the certifications on
the forms are not spelled out in the
rule text so they don't match that is a
legislative um intent issue and it is
throughout the rule in several places
for the different forms
um a conditional approval would have
fixed this
but
okay the a agency could say whether
that good morning uh my name is Emily
Jones I'm the rules coordinator for the
solid waste management Bureau of the
department um and also the compliance
supervisor Jamie Colby I'm supervisor of
the engineering and permitting section
and the solid waste management Bureau uh
we collectively have worked quite a bit
on these rules so hopefully if you have
collectively well the issue is that the
certifications on the forms don't match
the certifications in the rule text and
that can only be uh fixed with either a
preliminary objection or a postponement
approval question sorry trying to figure
out the
question so would you like the committee
to postpone and you come back with a
conditional approval or would you prefer
a preliminary objection to come back
with a change text um why don't we do
the which would get us a quicker uh
turnaround time because these are these
are pretty you know relatively
straightforward edits that we can make
probably the conditional approval would
be quicker okay you wouldn't you
wouldn't have to come back okay in that
to us no yes you'd have to come back
to they haven't filed a conditional
approval so you'd have to postpone and
they would file a conditional approval
for the November me do November meeting
October meeting sorry October meeting
okay okay okay so the committee want to
postpone to ask for M I move to postpone
the rule and to provide the department
more time to submit a conditional
approval second all right thank you
representative hacken Phillips in our
deadline is October 28th so it looks
like we wouldn't even need a waiver
thank you very much thank you oh excuse
me the motion is
to um postpone this those in favor I
opposed all right thank you thank you
all
right all right the installation
Standards
Board okay this is 20
2485 installation and manufactured
housing
standards um the rules are expired they
expired um in May of
2023 and the other issue is there's a
citation that normally we would do as an
edit but it's it's the rule says
305a and it's I think it's two supposed
to be 205d so it's enough of a change
issue good morning Tina Kelly rules
coordinator office of professional lure
and certification we can make that
change as
requested um and with regards to the
expiration of these
rules um the first part is that um
normally the towns if they have staff
towns and cities if they have staff they
do these inspections the oplc does not
um but however if um a town or does not
have somebody to do the inspections they
will request that the oplc do them using
the board's
rules and um we've only had one in
request in the past year which was done
and there were no
um nothing found there were no and I
don't want to use the word violations
but there were no um citable violations
citable violations
found and to that extent any of the
inspections would be done based off of
the law and it's very explicit in 205- D
colon 3 and 205- D Po in five what the
inspection should include when it should
happen and how it should
happen um you do mean 502 not 205 205 I
mean what's two what does 205 have to do
with these rules these are these are 500
or formerly 500 current
600 I mean the RSA 205d oh the RSA I'm
sorry RSA excuse me thank you I was no
wonder I'm confused I'm not used to S
short
numbers all right
so uh but
the the fee for inspections in expired
in
2013 and I don't believe oplc has charge
it until
they um got their rules in
replaced and where is where is the fee
citation well I'm just looking at your
the your summary on on the just you know
the last bullet is that
former rule
50205 which expired
51513 describ the Fe fees and it's not
included in the set of rules so where
are the fees okay they they will be in a
um any citations to fees within the
board's rules as I'm working on these
rules because theirs are expired will
point to op
LC's rules PLC
1,000
so so the so that they are not included
here and those those PLC rules were
effective August 1st of last year of
this year last year last year okay did
they include the manufactured housing
inspections I mean because I as I recall
it those fees were uh we've been adding
to them if I might help mam chair I
think this has to do with that huge
house bill
655 and I think House Bill the
manufacturing portion of that the
amendment to that was dealt with last
year um so I guess the question would
have been if the rules if the rules for
the fees had expired in
2013 and op PLC wasn't given the
Authority for the fees until let's say
even last year what happened between
2013 and
2023 that I do not know um I checked on
whether or not they had enforced the
rules how they enforc them I did not
look into what the fees were because
they weren't in here
specifically the fees are in PLC
100117 for inspections okay thank you so
we're covered for the most recent
year for the decade before that we're
uh we're wondering what the board did
that I do not know I can find
out thank you
curiosity we would very much like to
know because this is a recurrent concern
I will get that information and get it
to you okay
um so these
are the complete rules other than the
correct these are the correct and
complete rules for inspecting manufactur
housing installations and there's no
other part that needs to be included but
not with this set but there they have
other rules that will be coming through
expired okay so you have a whole bunch
of of expired rules as well as the fees
all right that's correct and I'm working
on all those to get them through as fast
as possible thank
motion I'm just trying to figure out
what the appropriate motion would be it
would be a motion for oral conditional
approval I'm sorry can you repeat that
it would be a a motion for an oral
conditional approval request okay so
moved I moved a I'll move a um motion
for oral conditional request second
okay so I so if I understand correctly
the housing insulation uh board was
moved to oplc quite
recently correct okay so
we it's all right thank you any further
comments question those in favor I
oppose all right good luck thank you and
we would like to know what happened with
year all
terrain these rules were inter rules and
they expired in
any other
comments the only other comment um was a
Clarity comment um on page
four the department is using so major
potential harm means a substantial
likelihood of causing harm to human
health or environment or the environment
and it also uses moderate likelihood and
small likelihood and there was just
there was some discussion about how
clear that is it's a little subjective
but it's also you know they're trying to
to create a a scale of how how they
would um meter out fines and there is a
there's a table at the bottom that kind
of shows what those would be if you know
you had a moderate deviation with
potential
harm so there is a Clarity issue there
but okay and so I am Courtney Lockwood
I'm one of the staff at attorneys for
the Department of Environmental
Services and rainy peler I'm the Water
Division director at
Dees um so we've been before you before
about this issue with these fine rules
that expired in 2008 um and we are in
the process of adopting rules specific
to each program that requires a schedule
of fines um and so this is the
alteration of terrain rules that are
before you so that we can try to fix
this issue we have not been charging
fines absolutely in any program that
doesn't have a schedule of fines since
early
2022 for the alteration of terrain
program I don't have specific numbers
it's rare for us to go for fines in this
particular program um our preferences
for compliance and Restoration in all of
our programs anyways but alteration of
terrain in particular um if we find out
someone didn't get a permit we try to
get them to go through the process to
get an after the fact permit and restore
any areas that might have been damaged
as a result of not having the permit in
our review so this so these are fines
primarily for not having a a permit it's
not just for having a permit you could
also have a permit that has conditions
and you violated the conditions or
didn't follow the permit um those are
less common for us but that does happen
Okay um there's also some technical
rules in here that were meant to address
um some objections that the Home
Builders Association raised last fall um
so this isn't just the fine rules it's
also to address those concerns that you
all heard last fall thank
you repres gr just for a question for
the gel car I do believe that we had
something last we something before us
already by the Home Builders Association
for terrain did we not so that was last
fall we had adopted new rules in
September and then the Home Builders
Association sent you all a letter I
believe in October or November I don't
remember the exact dates raising some
objection
um and the instructions from this
committee was for all of us to meet and
try to sort it out and we did that and
this is the result of that the fine
rules had nothing to do with the Home
Builders Association we just already
knew we needed to do those so the
previous rules were the technical rules
on how to apply and what the criteria
were correct and this is about the
mostly the fines this is mostly about
fines there are two rules in there that
were amended in order to address the
home builders
association's concerns okay we added
some flexibility basically I'm sorry we
added some flexibility to our rules to
address always a good
idea any other questions representative
Alon um thank you madam chair my
question was just around the minor
moderate and major potential for harm
and I just wasn't sure if there is any
way because it's hard to prescribe that
going forward to sort of review it after
the fact to make sure that it's been
consistent and see if there's any role
changes needed for clarity is there a
process for
that for reviewing what how they're
interpreting it
yes these rules are new it's the same
language that was adopted in other fine
rules we can't really seem to figure out
a way to word it differently keep in
mind these are proposed fines so the
criteria is this to help us determine
proposed fines but then the person has
the right to a hearing um and so the
decision is actually made at the hearing
this is just guidance that we used to
initiate the proposal to fine and this
is um the exact verbatim language as
other proposals in that have been
approved in the past and like I said we
we talked about it a lot and I I can't
figure out how El to it either so so so
these numbers you say well this moderate
moderate we don't really know which all
right we'll we'll we'll try we'll find
you
$1,250 and that's the start of the
negotiation yes okay either negotiation
or it goes to a hearing well at the
hearing I'm sure there are negotiations
even if the hearings examiner makes the
decision
yes I have a question represent so the
permit is issued by your department yes
follow up follow up and so if someone
let's say Mr Smith is an inspector and
he finds so and so
$1,250 how is it possible that different
is it the same person that issues the
fines that has the criteria for this how
these findes issued and is it is it if
because two people could have two
different standards right they could
have two differ definitions of what
moderate is all administrative fine
actions go through our legal unit so
it's centralized of who makes that
decision in our legal unit um and we
just make the decision of what is
proposed and bring that action um and
then it's up to the hearing officer and
ultimately our commissioner that makes
the final decision so the hearing
officer makes a recommendation based on
the hearing and the commissioner makes
the final decision last followup follow
up so in the rules um you define this
the significantly altered
characteristics of the terrain right
because that's what so is it possible
that within that definition you can I'm
going to assume that it's basically how
much dirt you move and you know that's
the basics of it yes right how much
Earth you have Disturbed yes exactly
Disturbed you and in relationship to
protected
land whether it be Wetland Shoreland you
know I mean it's in relationship to that
correct uh not necessarily um this is
for regulation of storm water so it's
okay so um if if you are close to say
protected shorel they um you can disturb
less land and still need a permit
correct correct correct the general
criteria is 100,000 square feet but
there are situations where it could be
less and you would still need a permit
so has the department looked at
relationship to this moderate maximum
minimum thing the amount of dirt moved
and is that a criteria that you could
use no no no
okay it's where the dirt was moved from
and to as much as how much I
imagine thank you all right any other
questions
comments all right does does somebody
motion I'd like like to comment that I'm
extremely concerned that your cross
program rules expired better than 15
years ago and you're just now getting
around to setting the fines
and that that
seems very
unprofessional and we assure you that
that's what we're trying to fix and I'm
also assuring you a commissioner for
several years now has said if you don't
have fine rules you are not proposing
fines so every program installed until
we have
fines but we only have so many staff to
propose rules so we're we're trying to
get through them all all right thank you
repres so sorry I have another question
so you had a public hearing for these
proposed rules and what was a what was
the comment to those rules into the
potential fines there's starting on page
six There's a summary of comments and
response there thank you
and it says that no member of the public
provided comments we had um a few people
show up but did not comment and then we
didn't receive any written public
comments
[Music]
okay I'm amazed that you managed to get
an alteration of of uh terrain no matter
how narrow through uh without any public
comment so I've got to congratulate you
on that part thank you we were surpris
motion we're all going now we don't want
to do it either you know well is this
similar to the previous proposal where
we have questions that that we can give
them an
oral conditional no because we don't
know specifically what we want them to
change them to for for conditional
approval we have have to have a specific
SE section saying change
this um in this case it's only the
concern about the expired rules appears
to be the only noticeable
comment so um in that case I will move
to
issues second by representative Lynn
anyone
else comments
questions way to run a rail
those in favor I was
opposed thank you and uh I hope your
your uh other rules are moving right
along thank you all right speaking of
fund so these rules are also expired but
let me find the
year more recently I hope more
recently sorry I lost my place here we
go um expired uh July of
2024 so much more recently all right so
um and the only note I have on on here
is that there is um it's it's the Sino
bacteria mitigation fund and so there
are contracts that are made with the
people that are getting the funds and
the grants um that's usually not
something that we can evaluate from a
rules perspective
um but the the kind of Meet the guts of
the contract are in the rule text and
they also go through um governor and
Council for approval so that's kind of
how that function works it's just it's
not all written out in the rule because
okay any
comments again Courtney Lockwood
attorney for Dees Amy smula I'm a
freshwater biologist at De
yes I don't have any comments on the
loan piece of this um we have another
set of rules with this exact same
language um the sorry the drinking water
State revolving fund rules um which is
where we pulled the language from that
was approved previously I believe in
2021 in terms of expiration um this was
a new uh statute and so we had to
quickly adopt interim rules that is what
expired in July um and so this isn't
about taking money this is about giving
out
money um so I think we've only received
one application since the time they've
expired and we are within our without
rules we have 60 days to make a decision
and we're still within our 60 days to
make a decision so we decided to hold
off on making decision since we did not
have rules um but if these are approved
today they will be adopted in time so
that we can still meet the 60-day
deadline under 541a
to make a decision and we will have the
criteria for approval to be able to do
that how
convenient all right anyone else
comments
questions okay Senator Chanley moves to
approve second second by representative
grassy any comments questions those in
favor I I
Grant they're holding off on the one
request I think that's about all we can
ask them to
do okay
HHS so this is proposal 202 4108
protected income level the only comment
I had on this was a note to the
committee because the notice states that
the rule is implementing For the First
Time chapter 39 laws of
2020 I did look into the legislative
history of this statute and even though
it took effect on June 30th 2021 it was
then temporarily suspended um under
chapter 91 laws of
2021 which took effect July 1st 2021
and then was
reinstated uh effective January 1st 2023
so even though the law first came in
effect on
2020 it really hasn't been fully in
effect since January 1st 2023 but that's
still is over a year since the statute
went into effect so my note was just
questioning why it took so long uh to
get this rule into place after that one
into
effect yes thank you we'd like to know
that could I can understand it being
suspended by hb2 but uh that's been a
while sure uh good morning Nicole
valenzula administrative rules
coordinator for Department of Health and
Human Services uh so yes so the chapter
law did go in effect
1123 which did Issue then authority to
DHHS to be able to begin to implement
this and do internal processes and
changes and the state plan approval
which did immediately happen and this
did benefit recipients immediately and
we started doing that uh and then it did
just take us longer to get the rule into
place we got held up a little bit with
some Financial conversations internally
and with
LBA um and here we are so do do I
understand you correctly to say that you
started implementing the law in
2023 and are just now getting around to
having the rules yes so we began
implementing it through because we did
have statutory authority to do that and
we had to update the state plan and we
did do that internal processes were done
documents policy changes everything went
out began immediately helping those
individuals who receive these this P the
protective income limit increase that
began working on the rule hit some bumps
things got held up and we've just
continued to work it and we're here now
to have it adopted so it sounds like the
rule is an afterthought is that correct
or is it the just the last step in a
very long it's a last step of a long
process that also got tripped up
internally with conversations and with
LBA uh Rob Barry General counsil to the
division of Medicaid DHHS to be clear
the the chapter law itself is very
prescriptive as to how we were to
implement this so um the the rule is
really just a recitation of the results
of the chapter law but the chapter law
really controlled here uh traditionally
the legislature has not been so
prescriptive as to how to implement the
protective income liit limit which is
why we've needed rules in the past uh
and we'll need rules going forward um
but this was just kind of a uh a unique
uh piece of legislation uh so we were
relying on that Authority and we did
feel that it was more important to get
the state plan amendment in place which
was our federal authority to implement
uh as well as inform the field and
develop processes so this could be
applied so the long and the short of it
is um no one was uh harmed by our um
deficiency here with getting this rule
in place and we do recognize that we
were deficient with that and we should
have done it a lot sooner than that but
I did want to clarify that um what the
process
was all right thank you madam chair
other questions yes uh just to clarify
the chapter law though it does give the
commissioner of the department uh the
authority to amend the income
eligibility requirement for in andout
medical assistance it gives the
commissioner two options it says that it
can e uh the commissioner can either
amend
uh less than or equal to
133 13% of the section 1931 income limit
or using methodology as described in
section 1902 R2 of the federal Social
Security Act so there was some choice to
be made by the department that had to be
done via rule
we elected the first uh option just for
clarity okay thank
you questions comments concerns move to
approve second second okay move by
representative Schmidt second by
representative L
discussion those in favor I
opposed thank
you okay passenger traway safety rules
okay so this is proposal 2024 145
various passenger Tramway safety
rules there were a couple of unclear
comments uh for this proposal the agency
did not file a conditional approval
request to address those issues the
first appears on page one of the rule
text it's an edit unclear comment uh due
to the citation of the Incorporated
material being different than other
sections where it's cited as as well as
an appendix B uh in that particular spot
it is cited as a nsib b 77.1
d222 but everywhere else it's an nsib b.
77-
2022 so it's unclear
because it either is an editorial error
which can be easily fixed or this is a a
different part of the document in which
case that needs to be cited specifically
in appendix 2 the second comment is on
the bottom of page that that sounds like
something we'd like to get out of the
way
sure hi good morning uh my name is
Briggs Lockwood I am the chief uh for
the for the Department of Safety of the
uh Tramway and amusement ride Bureau so
um oh yeah goad good morning my name is
Michael duu I'm one of the staff
Safety so yeah I think it is just an
editorial we're talking about the same
document um in in all of the places and
it looks like it was an oversight and in
one place it was uh
listed differently all right thank
you so so so the
uh the statute has been
updated I mean not the statute the
standard the NC standard has been
updated uh this is the latest version of
the an standard which we wish to adopt
version thank you okay anyone else I'm
version okay so that's
2022 so that issue could easily be fixed
with an oral conditional approval um but
there's still still two other
substantive comments but I also just on
that issue of the updated Incorporated
document I also just want to make the
committee aware that the department did
submit a summary of the changes which
was included in the packet because it
looks like there were some pretty uh
quite a number of changes um and it
looks like that summary comes directly
from the organization uh who updated the
document that seems highly
appropriate uh the second substantive
comment is on the bottom of page two
it's a unclear edit comment the notice
for this proposal stated that a
definition was added to this particular
section of the rule however it's unclear
what term was being defined as it was
not laid out in compliance with the
manual and it was not specified so in
that particular
section it's either new installation or
modification I couldn't determine which
term was meant to be defined or if both
were meant to be defined
and then Additionally the setup of that
particular rule is not in compliance
with the manual as they have language
right after the section title but it's
not introductory language for the
subsequent paragraphs it simply seems to
be its own paragraph So that entire
section needs to be
reconstructed well that sounds like an
editorial
comment but the uh so you have the
modific so the modification
is the new definition and you're
basically redefining it as a new
installation I do understand the
confusion here really the intent here
was to
describe um what would occur um
involving a new installation if if
there's movement if there's an
alteration in length or movement of the
passenger Tramway and that the end
result would consider it a new
installation it wasn't the intent was
not to Define new installation per
se okay so is there a def new definition
in this
section I I would say no oh
okay so that issue if it was just a
discrepancy between the notice and the
role text is fine um so it'll just the
remaining issue would be to restructure
that section to be in compliance with
the manual by having appropriate
introductory language for those sub
paragraphs
which might take a little more work than
a oral conditional approval that we
could do right here um and then
additionally there is one final comment
on the bottom of page three it's an
unclear comment uh the rule requires
that plans to replace a prime mover
motor or plans to change or replace a
control system shall be submitted to the
department along with the application
and
specifications however the rule then
goes on to state that the department
shall allow the completion of the
modification testing of the submitt if
they meet the standards but then the
board shall review the application at
its next scheduled board meeting and
should determine if the modifications
conform with the standards so it's
unclear who exactly is making the
decision of whether they meet the
standards and also if it is ultimately
the board who makes that determination
why the department is allowed to give an
initial approval prior to the board's
decision
I have an answer for that
um in this day and age where uh the
electrical systems the that control the
the motive parts of the ski lifts and
the control systems that monitor these
machines that are mile a mile long these
systems are becoming so sophisticated
and as I'm sure we all can understand
they become obsolete after not very long
um a a ski resort may be faced with uh
having to
replace some of these components which
uh by definition it's a modification of
the Tramway if it's not exactly the same
part
number and once a some these components
become five or six years old the you
cannot buy the same part number they're
forced into this modification the
Trouble Is We would have to convene the
Tramway board uh in order to act on this
uh under the current situation so what
the board agreed to
do um in order to expediate this for the
businesses that are trying to operate
this equipment is to submit the designs
um to the department and have us review
them and that way they can move forward
with the installation and testing and
operation and then the board would then
review it so the board effectively is
agreeing to defer that to us for the
temporary period of time until the next
their next meeting so
the what happens if the board decides
that the application is not
correct well it says they will identify
the area or areas of non-conformance and
stipulate a reasonable time frame for
conformance okay so
the the owner of the lift is that is on
the hook for making sure the board has
approved their design modifications that
is
correct thank you I thought that was the
case any other questions no
comments get you got to do it you got to
do it kind of as built how to build it
to
the situation
right right and you test it see that it
works that is correct yeah we would
require uh a a quality qualified
engineer to review and stamp the project
and that engineer then is responsible
for any testing testing would be
completed and so it's really the same
drill that would happen with the board's
approval they're just deferring
everything to us so that to so that it
can be done okay well there's also that
um um Clarity issue that needs a
rewrite could we move to um give them a
conditional approval and come back
in so we could postpone and allow the
department to submit a conditional
approval um also looking at the
rule was the intent to
have
that language right after the section
title just as its own paragraph and each
subsequent paragraph is its own
paragraph This is section uh pass
35.035683
the bottom of page two I think we'll
still have a because if that's the case
then we can do an oral conditional
approval to just move that make that
paragraph a and relet the remaining
paragraphs if they're all Standalone
paragraphs and then additionally fix
that citation okay we're not opposed to
make that change per per what uh the
committee would like us to do making it
a new paragraph is simple enough that
the oral request would would be
valid okay so we so we have a motion
second and just comments questions wait
a minute are we are we seconding my
motion my motion was to
postpone was not an oral conditional
approval should I change my motion would
that be like to sure I'll change it to
an oral conditional approval I just want
to make sure that we have the same
motion I will draw my first one and I'll
change it to this second all right by
motion by representative groda to
conditionally approve this with the
editorial comments indicated and second
by representative
Schmid any sorry representative Lenn
excuse
me all right any comments questions
concerns those in favor
I
opposed thank you very much thank you
all right representative fellows you're
sitting in for representative Schmid
since he has another meeting to go to
yes I do all right any
um
and under the Department of Natural and
cultural resources we have three
administrative rules uh three emergency
rules Madam chair yes I I think there is
one item before that
I'm not on the agenda I have it goes I'm
sorry I was straight from the passenger
traway safety board to other thank you
um we have representatives from the
Department here uh my concern with all
three of these proposals and I'm going
to discuss all of them together is
whether or not there's actually imminent
Peril to Public Health or safety or
substantial fiscal harm to the state or
its citizens
the attachments to each of the uh um
emergency rules which uh go into the
details of why uh don't seem to state
that there's an imminent Peril or
substantial fiscal harm um so this's
question there of whether it falls
within the definition of an emergency
role also I would note that um the
department has beened en forcing the
rules uh created by
dread uh those were were um done in
2014 since then as you know dread uh has
been split into two one of the
Department's natural and cultural
cultural
resources um these rules the rules that
they were enforcing from dread expired
on March 1st of 24
uh so the department had seven years to
go through regular ruem or interim ruem
to put these into place there's also
been enough time since March 1st to
adopt either regular rules or interim
rules
um so again it the need for these at
this moment uh outside of regular
yes I would agree that the the question
is
why why is this an emergency when you've
had six months since March
to adopt The Dread rules as inur rules
which would be a very simple thing to
do good morning my name is torine tangal
Loi I am with the division of Parks and
Recreation as a program specialist and I
assist the division and Department with
their rules
um and we are the division is in the
process of updating its rules we've not
been able to uh finalize some decisions
on the rules uh with the commissioner
and director they're still reviewing
some of these rules both uh commissioner
and director especially are fairly new
to the department and division so
they're still uh contemplating some of
the rule changes that we were wanting to
make we submitted administrative rules
um and we uh are not particularly
uh practiced on rule making and uh we're
not aware that interim rule may have
been a better uh process to keep these
rules in play while we finish regular R
making yes cuz that would in fact be the
appropriate it's you're specifically
allowed to adopt interim rules to
effective director moral I would note
that there are two other issues related
to this uh one is
that under the rules that have expired
there's fee making Authority and well
the regular fee for state parks are
exempt from
541a however administrative fines are
not also there's a separate statute uh
regarding Hampton Beach for which the
department is responsible for the
parking uh which includes fees for
parking or parking meters and fines for
failure to
comply additionally
um
well I I also want to inform the
committee that the
department a few years ago adopted
natural heritage inventory program rules
but no other rules have come forward uh
the department has no chapter 100
organizational rules or chapter 200
practice and procedure
rules all right well that's a
challenge uh the the question I have is
have you been enforcing
have you been collecting any fines since
March which I imagine this is your busy
season yes we have um with regards to
the parking um fees to park along the
Sea Coast as well as the fines for
violations of parking we have been
enforcing
that you realize that that's
okay I would note that uh I believe the
fines and I'll double check with Kim but
I think the $250 fine is set by Statute
yeah the statute at um 12
a2c caps the fines at
$250 but does require the agency to
develop a schedule of fines and
procedures for those fines right well
well if it's set as a
maximum I mean I understand most
agencies interpret that as the minimum
but realistically you could you could be
giving out $50 you could choose to give
out $50
enrolled all right anyone else
comments I I have a
question so are we saying that there is
no Fe schedule in these rules there is a
fee schedule in these rules in these
rules okay but they their previous
Authority expired in March correct I
understand so if you got a parking
ticket at Hampton beach this summer it
was illegal well if you paid for parking
at Hampton Beach
correct if if I may as well uh clarify
something um so the department also has
statute that allows it to um set its
feed
and uh present them to the Joint
legislative fiscal
committee so uh such as our insance fees
admission fees um it includes our
parking fees and fines that was
submitted to fiscal Comm committee and
approved so that is those are some of
the fines and fees that we are working
off
of yeah the iror Marl is is it correct
that the fees and fines would have to be
approved both by fiscal and by jail car
that appears to be uh the fees for state
parks uh does have an exemption from
541a as I mentioned however the fines
for any state
park um are through
rules although the statute caps it and
any fees or fines for Hampton uh Hampton
Beach parking uh would need to go
through
rules unless there is another statute
that I missed which is always
possible don't think there were any
changes so what are what are our options
in this because these are emergency
rules uh the committee cannot object if
the committee fails that there is no
legitimate emergency then it can
petition the department to repeal their
emergency rules and
uh the committee may wish make
recommendations about adopting rules uh
these rules for regular rule making
200s does someone wish to make a motion
recommendation request that's about all
we can do is ask representative Roa does
your department have a rules
coordinator she just retired like two
weeks
ago and so I've been assisting her
through the years on Division division
of Parks and Recreation rules um to my
so if we
don't what they if we take your your um
position that or we support your
position that these are the emergency
rules are not
warranted what's the I mean what would
option that we keep
things you know
the department could undertake interim
Ru making
immediately uh to put the old rules back
into place um even though those were
dread rules I think they could still use
the interim rule process to put them in
as uh rules under this
department and that would start with a
motion from
us uh the committee can make that motion
but the department could do that at any
time
all we can do is
point we we can strongly request yes yes
right all right and I would second in a
strong request all right so I'll make a
strong request from the committee that
the department undertake interim rle
making
immediately and that when would they be
coming back
here actually if the emergency rules
stay in effect commit committee doesn't
petition them or the committee petitions
them and they deny the petition then
those rules are in effect for six months
making which I understand that you are
in the middle of regular rul making on
are okay and we would I think that
perhaps we should say that they should
continue the regular rul making on these
and they should adopt as interim rules
all the procedural rules from dread that
they are undoubtedly following but don't
have in in
effect that yes yes so moved all right
second by representative grassy yeah you
should adopt as interim rules rules all
the rest of the dread rules that you
should
have for your
operations as well as continuing the
regular rul making for these
rules thank you repres um thank you
madam chair um Mr moral in order for um
I guess I'm trying to understand the
process regarding the emergency rules
and us not seeing them as reasonable did
you say that we would petition to say
that the emergency rules are not valid
what would be that process to then move
this to the inter rules and the regular
Ru making if the committee feels that
there is not a legitimate emergency uh
it's only option is to petition the
agency to repeal those rules the agency
has to respond uh within 30 days by
letter and I would make I think it would
probably make sense to make that motion
so I'd make that
motion I'll second
it okay
can I just representative L said I I I I
understand the the sentiment behind the
motion and the and the response but I
just kind of I mean it it it seems like
it's not only with this agency but what
we've heard today that there is sort of
generally a problem um with with having
rules kept up on time and my only
concern here is that if we file this
thing uh if we F if we make this motion
that is
suggested what the that what that's
going to mean is that the department is
now going to have to devote time to
responding to that and presumably which
will take away from their time from from
actually working on on the rules and so
I wonder if you know is it are we sort
of biting off our our head to spite our
hand that's my only concern about Madam
chair Senator I see what you're saying
we want them to focus but actually don't
have to have to respond they could just
accept that and just move forward on the
interim rules I you know I understand
sort of the dilemma here and also we
have a very clear sort of legislative
prescription about when emergency rules
are appropriate so I think it's more
appropriate uh for them to move into
interm rule making yes and and I'm kind
of amazed that in seven
years the department has not moved on
any rule making except one narrow
concern I just have a question yes
clarifying I thought there were I don't
believe there are two motions on the
table right now but perhaps there are or
can I just be the mo representative broa
made a motion and we are discussing it
okay but I thought representa Leon also
made a motion she said she wanted to
make a motion okay got it thank you
thank you
and so if you could represent BR if you
could restate the motion that we're
we're discussing or trying to all right
so I'm gonna I'm going to try to
remember theemotion is that the that we
strongly recommend to the request we
strongly request that the
department um continue its Ru making
process but
start the interim rule making process
for those rules that are not in the
making
process and that um was there third part
of
this was that it well the third part is
what what kind of fines did they collect
over oh that's right and what kind of to
report to us what kind of fins
and
unauthorized income was collected by the
department IT director moral I'm
somewhat concerned about uh asking them
to go through interim rul making for
other rules such as the 100 and 200
rules the reason being an interim rule
like that to bring back expired rules
the rules have to be the exact same
language uh organizational rules
describe the organization describe the
AG agency a description of dread would
not be the same as this department U so
I'm not as I say I'm not sure that it
would be appropriate I can go and look
at the 100 rules and the 200 rules and
talk with the agency about it and report
committee just to clarify they're not
currently in formal rule making I looked
up on our database and there there is no
current rule making taking place so if
they're doing any that might be
agency okay do you wish to amend your
I'll amend my motion
um we strongly recommend that the
department takes on interim Ru
making so
that you have the authority that you
need and that you
include in that the
specific Authority that you have in
collecting fines and issuing fees which
are in your emergency rules which we're
not going
to obviously approve we we don't have to
approve
right everybody clear
Madam chair yes I just think it'd be
important for jel car to to ask the
department to
um take an internal assessment of its uh
rule making and rules on hand to
determine if they need to initiate other
rules as well it sounds like this one uh
flipped through the slep through the
cracks so um it might be worth a second
look to make sure that there are not
other
concerns I can add that to my motion
that's a very good
point a second the motion second okay
any further comments questions director
moral I I'm still concerned about the
using the interim process if it's going
to be used the motion doesn't mention
interim it just says that they continue
their their Ru making and that
they assess their rules or the previous
Department rules to see what rules they
need
understood
because this
rules that and for moving forward um
please don't hesitate to reach out to us
for help in the process I appreciate
that we will do that thank you all right
any other
comments amendments yes for director I
would ask if the gentleman could
identify himself for the record good
morning Colin Capel Chief of Staff
recation all right those in favor I I
opposed all right good luck okay thank
much then Madam chair yes um did we want
to look at petitioning the emergency
rules because without that petition they
would go into effect or is it is it have
we already made that statement they have
gone into effect Okay so we've already
made the statement that we're very
displeased that they did not take the
right path but we won't further burden
the department right okay thank
you
we when we get the strongly worded
letter from the staff we will distribute
all
right the last discussion item is the
letter from the Dr about the
equalization
manual um I read the letter and it
sounds like the agency was graveling
sufficiently um they basically said that
the people
that identified the equalization manual
as guidance and not a rule we wrong
and
that
the and they will be be
corrected uh the only concern I have
left is that the equalization manual is
adopted as a rule but some parts of it
are in fact guidance or suggestions
rather than actual rules so but that's
something that the Dr has to has to deal
with we've approved the equalization
manual as a
document and did anyone else read it or
it apparently not director moral I just
had one final note uh for the next two
committee meetings October and November
there will be two directors of
administrative roles here as some of you
know I'm retiring at the end of November
and we have hired new director but I'm
going to stay on for six weeks to help
train him uh it is Douglas osterhout uh
oplc
gently all right all right so I think we
are by consensus we're going to cancel
the continued meeting and uh adj Jed
anything else all right all right thank